there are a lot of fans that i think do
miss the characters that we've spent the
past couple years with what is your
message to them listen they're they're a
part of our family so there's references
and we definitely explain what's going
on everybody grows
and your family changes eventually we've
got adrian back on the show how did that
all come about listen i love adrian not
only does adrian come back but she has
such an important role
i'm okay you're enjoying this aren't you
i sure am now break it down
my queen in the building my queen what
up girl it is so good to see you raven i
want to flash back to the last time you
and i spoke
it was right after the season four
finale of raven's home
and you put me in a tailspin
you gonna get that
no not right now
raven is not home
will there be a season five
i cannot tell you the status of raven's
home because i don't know it myself do i
love my cast yes do i want to work with
him for as long as i can of course is it
my decision no
fast forward to 2022 ravens home season
five you're back and with a lot of
changes so i'm just curious what sparked
this whole reinvention of the ravens
home franchise
i have to be honest with you i lied to
you deidra i knew what was going to
happen and they wouldn't let me say it i
normally have like really good words to
cover up my lives but i just didn't have
anything good listen when they said they
wanted to do a fifth season i was like
okay cool
what's
what like
what's the journey for the characters
and when we knew the eps that were
coming back their minds
really worked together with disney
channel and had the most amazing thought
to bring raven baxter and her son to san
francisco and bring my father and show
another version of family again and
that's what i love about it we have such
diversity so many stories so many
journeys and you're gonna find someone
in this cast that will remind you of you
new characters new city um what are you
most excited for fans to experience with
this sort of i don't know soft reboot of
raven's home right it's a little bit of
a soft reboot um what i'm expecting
honestly is for
all the generations to sit down again
you have a grandfather you have a young
niece under the age of 10 and you have
um a millennial and you have a teenager
we're here to entertain you and start
conversation one of the things that i
loved about
that's so raven is yes we tackled body
and image and all of this but we did it
with a spoonful of sugar and that's what
we hope to do with this season as well
because there are so many changes to
season five were there ever
conversations or did you ever think
about should we just call the show
something new and start fresh no i will
be honest with you we did not want to
start the show new and start something
fresh because
we never considered raven's home a
reboot of that's a raven it was a new
show with characters that you knew from
a different show
and that this is what this is this is
not a different show this is just you
know in everyone's life you
create different families as you grow up
you go and visit old family you bring in
new friends this is just a continuation
of raven baxter and booker's life as he
grows into
a young man and she figures out what
she's doing with her life
well it's so exciting that we've got the
og dad back in the building rondell
sheridan
hey dad
do you love me more than my brother
no i love you both the same oh i knew it
how did that idea come about did you
pick up the phone and say i got to get
you back in my life and on this show i
just called him out of the blue i was
like so are you working are you going to
be on tv again you want to work with me
again he was like i kind of like you
yeah like i would i was like sweet he is
a connoisseur of comedy and it's
wonderful to be able to have such a
wonderful man on set
helping to
show all of the actors on this set what
old school comedy's about we've got the
kitchen and the old house and the chill
grill but but this time your character
is now you know calling him grandpa
i know how does that feel it's um
it's weird at times right i love saying
that i'm older i have no problem with
age i think it's fantastic trippy at all
to be in your old bedroom
it is very trippy uh there's a episode
where i'm helping my father out and i'm
like my old room dad if these walls
could talk
what would they say nothing even when i
said that you know i'm not i'm not a
dramatic actress okay i'm not very
method i just like to give you my lines
and act crazy on set but with that line
it truly made me think of the time that
chelsea and myself turned into cows the
time that i got my room redone by a
crazy person and moved into the basement
um
you know there's been so many stories
that i've been a part of
within this house and within this
character um
i can't it's just a lot amazing well
listen you just bring up chelsea and
while everybody i think is so excited to
be embracing and welcoming all these new
characters there are a lot of fans that
i think do miss the characters that
we've spent the past couple years with
um what is your message to them are you
going to offer some sort of closure to
the fans do we get references to those
characters like especially chelsea and
nia
of course yes for sure we're we're not
listen they're they're a part of our
family so there's references and we
definitely explain what's going on i
think that's very important because we
respect the people that are watching the
show
and you know like i said before
everybody grows
and your family changes eventually and
the people close to you change and it's
not it doesn't change you it hopefully
will help you grow as a human and it's
always good to have those people that
know you from your past and you call on
them and you reference so you know it's
it's about moving forward and of course
we pay homage to those who have got us
here okay so we'll we'll have closure
about where they are what they're up to
what they're doing
yes ma'am okay and then in terms of like
surprise cameos or even little like face
time moments i think fans would not only
love to hear from like chelsea and nia
but also
where is mom where is corey jennifer
lewis i mean are these names that you're
talking about possibly bringing in for
special moments
i am such a believer in making sure that
we can bring as many people as we can to
the show
um as possible and we
have only been picked up for one season
right now so there's only so much we can
do
but we are jam packing it with nostalgic
moments to the best of our abilities
well i you know me die hard og cheetah
girls fan my brain absolutely exploded
when i see adrienne houghton two years
ago she goes on the reel and she
[Applause]
alana
says
doing a lot of like line right now what
would she say she would just be mean
i did see that clip of her on tv and i
was like yes listen i love adrian i've
loved her since i met her when
the writers and i sat down and we were
like okay what's going to be the first
big oh my goodness you know bringing in
a nemesis is always the best because it
just brings conflict and funnies and all
that kind of stuff she is an important
part of the story and we keep her alive
and i love that i haven't seen you since
high school and yet it still feels too
soon welcome back baxter for you too to
meet us teenagers to be on set together
and then fast forward like a decade or
two
what goes through your mind when you're
on set with this woman who you have such
like a rich history with
it's it nothing goes through my mind
other than this is easy this is really
easy we just fell right into place her
name in my phone is chuchi which is the
name that we used to call each other on
cheetah girls and just being able to
talk to each other now that we're adults
and reminisce and root for each other
and our success has been such a
pleasurable moment i just thought you
were so wonderful and i can see your
voice so you're over in adrian's world
and then she's over in your world on
raven's home
at what point do we just have a
conversation about adrian and and raven
a stand-alone project the two of you
honey we so busy that's definitely
probably gonna happen but we're so busy
right now i think we love coming into
each other's worlds season six
who knows man i i'm not lying to your
face this time
we're really focused on creating this
content that hopefully will get us
another season but who knows
[Music]